data Inc made me realize how expressive
the pen can be and when I was thinking
about this project I was like I don't
have to think when I use the pen is just
like you know I'm just expressing myself
and I don't have to think of it how am I
gonna do it it's just so natural for me
I just put my bend down and then that's
the way it goes and so how cool would it
be if you know I could use this for just
expressing my thinking all the time
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger dr.
Nathalie rish envisions a future in
which all of our data will be accessible
meaningful compelling and artistic and
as a researcher in human-computer
interaction and information
visualization at Microsoft Research
she's working on technical tools that
will help us wrangle our data extract
knowledge from it and communicate with
it in a memorable persuasive and
aesthetically pleasing way in other
words she wants our data to be both
smart and beautiful today dr. Rees
shares her passion for the art of
data-driven storytelling reveals the two
superpowers of data visualization gives
us an inside look at some innovative
projects designed to help us think with
digital ink and tells the story of how a
young woman with an artist's heart
headed into computer science took a
detour to the beach paid for it with
research and ended up with a rewarding
career that brings both art and
computing together that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
Natalie rish welcome to the podcast I
like to start my podcasts by situating
my guests and their research so let's
situate you you conduct research in the
field of data visualization in broad
strokes
tell us what problems are you trying to
solve what questions are you asking what
gets you up in the morning I guess what
get me up in the morning is to be able
to create visuals from data that
actually can be useful to a lot of
people and you know everyone has data
whether it's like personal or at work so
that's sort of this unique opportunity
to try to leverage that and then help
people use that data right to gain
knowledge and insights and what really
get me up in the morning is this
creativity part because I have this data
that's really like you know ugly in some
ways and I have to make it sort of
inspiring and reach up inside and
synthesize it and I have to craft sort
of art from that data that could be also
hard that is you know useful and like
touching people it's really akin to art
right it's like how do you extract the
message and how do you best communicate
it and people are just very receptive to
things that are beautiful right and that
touch you emotionally or just simply
like you know stop you and make you look
at it let's talk a second about epic or
extended perception interaction and
cognition the group it's a thing year
I've had a few of your colleagues on the
podcast already and your work falls
under the larger umbrella of
human-computer interaction or HCI but
you follow specific lines of research
within that on smaller groups or teams
and epic is one of those so why this
particular group what does your team
bring to the HCI table mm-hmm we do epic
research well so first I really love our
group or group is very diverse
we don't really like focus on one
specific device but what we care about
is the experience
so from end to end experience for
example I care about inking so what do
people do with a digital pen in their
actual day-to-day job or life and so we
do care about the breadth of the
activity and not just one particular
domain or type of audience or task what
I really care about these days is how do
you help people think with this digital
ink because I think with ink all the
time right with pen and paper on my
whiteboard and so on so how can I really
super this broad activity right like
what do people do when they're thinking
and how can we help them think with
their device that has this pen right you
know drilling in just a little bit there
I write a lot for my job and I think on
a whiteboard and I have notebooks all
over the house in fact have filled
notebooks but I feel like there's a
connection there that I don't have right
now with any of my digital devices well
in fact that's what we try to bring to
the table in that software project like
the recent project we're doing you know
somehow we don't have that connection
with digital ink but yet digital ink can
do crazy things for you because it knows
like everything is in the computer so
could you imagine if you start writing
down some notes and then you bring you
back three of those idea you had in
those health-nut books all over the
place that's like this unique superpower
so that's the sort of things we want to
try to leverage bring that connection
but then also the power of the computer
speaking of superpowers you have said
famously to some degree that data
visualization has two superpowers okay
what are they why are they super
obviously young kids and they love
superheroes so I just give super powers
to everything in my life no so yeah data
visualization as to super power the
first one it's about identifying
insights and the way visualization does
this is by basically answering questions
you didn't even know you had about your
data so you just look at it and it's a
bit like looking at the
in the sky and then you see patterns and
it's not really that you were thinking
about those patterns right it's very
different from like running an analysis
test but it's more about something
you're noticing and that basically it
generates questions in your mind and
then that's like you know this making
you see through some of that data so
that always about the exploration like
sort of learning from your data and you
find things the second one is about
communication so a picture is worth a
thousand words right and when you see
the picture a lot of that superpower
that the visual has is just directly
going through your sensory system that's
what we call pre-attentive you're not
even aware that interesting it's like
opening in your brain and so you're
perceiving that message extremely fast
and so that's like the superpower of
communication that is you know much
faster than verbal or like textual and
so that's the superpower of
communication as a researcher you've
made it clear that you're not a data
scientist rather you work on building
tools that data scientists will be using
and we can extract from that to some
degree that that means you have to
predict the future about your thought
process as you seek to equip the next
generation data scientists with tools
for jobs that maybe haven't even been
invented yet
so first you know I do think about data
scientists like as we know them today
which helps yeah and I see a lot of them
struggle but I do think about you know
the future in which every one of us is
gonna be a data scientist because you
know we're gonna have even more access
to data and we're off to make decisions
from it so the tool I'm sort of thinking
are more and more designed towards
helping anyone tell with their data and
leveraging those two superpowers so sort
of the way I predict the future is
relying a lot of my own experiences what
I can learn what I can do I'm sort of
the super data scientist right like yeah
because I'm the you
my own tool that I haven't done yet this
is sort of trying to rely on my own
experience and then other people's
experience and so I spend a lot of time
observing people and like you know
watching them work and then trying to
sort of extract what are the key
activities that they're doing that we're
really don't support right now and then
trying to build tool to help support
those let's talk about the data
scientist for a second because that's
your kind of target audience even though
it has a broader application yes what do
they say to you when you talk to them
sort of upstream in your research about
the kinds of problems they're facing
what they wish they had and what they
wish they could do right so a lot of the
problem led to a lot of the research
that I've done like in the past five
years she's a lot of data scientists are
very good at what they're doing so
they're very good at basically getting
into the data and then I kind of
messaging it and then extract those
insights from it sure but one of their
key struggle is to actually transform
that insight into some communication
that they need to do to their upper
management or you know to other people
that aren't really that familiar with
the data or with the method or
technically sophisticated exactly and
you know you need to have this good
sense of design and a lot of data
scientists although some are really
amazing still they had some issue that
you know crafting aesthetically pleasing
charts or even memorable ones and so a
lot of this that's like sort of the
activity we call storytelling yeah and
so a lot of the struggle was about you
know once you have the data and then you
have the insights how do I sequence it
and message it and so that I have
actually a story with visuals out of all
of that masses of data and charts that
I've created well since you mentioned a
storytelling I want to wade upstream
before we get specific and talk about
this big idea of data-driven
storytelling you have a lot of research
projects going on in this space but
before we get granular give us a sort of
raise on debt if you will for
data-driven storytelling
so storytelling you know it's been there
forever right I mean that's the way
human communicated before they know how
to write right and in fact a lot of them
drew and so we sort of kept this going
on right that's one of the best way to
convince people and try to convince them
to make a decision and so storytelling
is really this notion that you can take
this person with you along the path of
your reasoning so that that person can
see your argument and understand them
and hopefully you know agree with you
all the way till you can make your point
and so what's really the point of the
storytelling is to demonstrate your
point you're making their substantiate
it by data it's not just like you know
out of my own brain but it's like data
that I've collected so that is somewhat
more objective than my own opinion and
so there's an art to it right you need
to have the story but you also need to
show that this is coming from the data
you've collected so that's where it's
become very difficult because you have
to link that data and the objective
facts and weave them into a story that
is logical and a progression and people
can you know come along with you and
then understand each step on the way and
then be able to sort of agree or
disagree or make their decision right so
it's interesting that you frame this in
terms of persuasion mm-hm and you're
talking about data and visuals and
stories how much emotion is necessary or
finds its way in a harness path that's
the big elephant in the room in the
field because we want to be truthful to
the data and objective but the reality
is you know emotion of a big impact yeah
and so and the visuals can carry a lot
of that emotion but it's also really
hard to measure yeah in fact we have a
teaming in HCI that works on this yeah
married servants kiss yeah but so
basically it's very hard to quantify but
it does a very strong impact and so
right now it's like a op
research problem well you can't really
extract it because any kind of a visual
a picture an image that you show will
probably have some kind of an impact on
a person looking at it and so you're
like we want it to be emotional enough
that we can move people along and
motivate and persuade but not so much
that it becomes propaganda exactly and I
guess a lot of that is also from the
data itself that's also hard to control
you know if I show you data about like
you know World War 1 World War 2 is very
different from sales in surface devices
although you know some people and
Microsoft might find it more emotion but
that is very hard to control and there
is a number of work that start tacking
this but it's still very sort of recent
research yeah
well let's get specific and start with a
super interesting project called data
toons this was highlighted in a paper
you just presented at CAI this year and
it made me want to be a data scientist
because I wanted to use it that's pretty
cool
tell us about data toons and what comics
are cartoons have to do with the very
serious field of data science yes when
we started to work on storytelling of
course my brain went to stories that I
read to my kids
and among those there's a lot of those
Illustrated stories and comics and so I
sort of stored that in part of my brain
and then went on with you know the more
sort of serious storytelling you're
making air quotes a lot in there but
then after a while I thought we should
really leverage this notion of comics
because they're very sequential and they
really are good at conveying you know
like temporal stories and so this whole
line of research started on how we can
leverage this jar of storytelling and
then make it data-driven and so that's
what we call the data comics so we've
done a lot of research on those data
comics
how are the differing from infographics
what sort of design principle we can use
people to create those and whether they
are effective as a storytelling
mechanism and a lot of those research
actually ended up in paper at the KY
conference yeah that you're citing and
then a lot of those papers gave us ideas
about a tool that could help you craft
those hmm and that too is data tuned and
given the work in orem group about pen
and touch and all of those devices that
we have at Microsoft we sort of tried to
leverage the super studio and then try
to offer this nice pen and touch
experience to craft comics from your
data and so basically what we end up
doing is you load some data set that you
have could be an Excel spreadsheet you
know of your finances yeah please know
and you're basically drag and drop part
of it to create panels and then as you
duplicate panels and you change the date
and time or like you change the style or
you change you know some of the focus of
the part of the data you're caring about
you're basically creating the sequence
of panels and you lay them out in space
and becomes a comic nice so that's the
idea behind this data toon where does
that live right now is it still sort of
in research or is this downstream and I
could get it if I had a surface it's in
between so it's online so we like to do
a lot of for to like on the web nowadays
so it's a website you can just go to
okay it's research in the sense that
it's a prototype so you know it doesn't
handle tons of data and you know it's
not really ready for massive usage but
but you can use it with some of your
data and then you can craft comics and
the whole idea behind it is really to
help the research community and people
interested in trying to create comics
and then see the sort of comics they
could create right and then reflect upon
those and figuring out the sort of
comics that are created whether you know
people enjoy this medium or not yeah
this work that you're doing is
incredibly visual as if that weren't
obvious from the data visualization and
here we are in an audio podcast so I'm
gonna encourage our listeners to hit up
the Microsoft Research website and go to
your page
Natalie rish that's n-ath a li e RI CH e
and look at some of the videos of this
work because it's really cool the demos
that you've got showing how it works and
we can't really convey that you're doing
a good job with words thanks anyway
well create a visual expression which is
kind of what we're talking about writ
large is always a challenge given that
most people can't draw and most data
visualization tools are actually
designed for data professionals of one
sort or another but your team has
developed a tool called data Inc for
people who might want to express
personal data more beautifully or to a
less professional audience
and this is a really cool project
because it was inspired by another
really cool project called dear data so
give us a bit of the backstory on dear
data and how it informed your work on
data Inc and where that lives now so
dear data is such a fascinating project
like when I learned about it my heart
burst with love for those people and
basically Georgia and Stephanie
there are both designers and one is in
New York and one lives in London so
every week they would go about
collecting data about their life so they
would agree ahead of time about what
sort of data to collect and then it
would collect that data and then at the
end of the week craft a unique
visualization that highlights that data
and you know some insight about that
data and then craft this unique and
whimsical visualization of their
personal data they would actually draw
it on a postcard and then send it to
each other
and so they did this every week for a
year can you imagine like that's sort of
the dream of any write researcher
because you have all that data plus the
visual language and they're all like
beautiful and they're all very unique
and each convey those emotions about the
data so this was just so inspiring and
knowing that a lot of those postcard
they're created by a very simple shape
so you know you mentioned earlier like
you don't know how to scare it so hard
to draw but you know how to draw a
circle yeah and you know how to draw an
arc so a lot of those composition
they're composed by very simple shapes
that anyone can draw but yet putting
them together it's like this just unique
beautiful art but it's also meaningful
art right yeah that tells you a story
about little piece of you and so when
looking at this were just so inspired
and we thought that must be such you
know hard work first to collect that
data and then to draw it because they
actually did sometimes spend hours just
redrawing it and so we said maybe but
making it easier people could benefit
from you know working with their data
and
be sharing it with others without the
dedication required to spend hours
drawing on a postcard right and the
other thing is once you're invested in
this one idea you just go for it because
it's so long you know entities so you
can really change your mind as you're
doing it because it's so tedious like if
you have done half of your data you're
like I'm just tipping this circle so we
said also that the digital device could
help you sort of change your mind
because it will just populate the entire
data visualization you know you should
change your mind from circle to square
it's sort of done in a second so we
developed this tool called data Inc
where you can start from a sketch and
then you can bind properties of that
sketch so say the color of the circle or
like the stroke width of the circle to a
data property and basically generates
the entire visualization for all of your
data so what I'm hearing is that you've
got the tactile human interface of pen
and touch and then you have the power of
a digital tool underneath that so the
computer is basically assisting you
right so you sort of give the command
and it just does it to all of your data
so imagine if you've collected you know
2,000 sleep pattern yeah you know you're
deciding about the way you want to
encode it so oh I'm gonna use shades of
colors for like how long I slept every
night and once you've decided about that
color palette then basically you tell
the computer okay just do it for it mm
ro fill yes yes that's it yes okay so
we've got these threads of data toons
data Inc there's another project I want
to talk about which is called active ink
so when we think about traditional data
visualization tools or even other CAD
tools computer assisted drawing we think
about the classic computer user
interface of a mouse a keyboard and a
screen but it's much more natural for us
to use our hands and pens via touch
and you haven't answered to that to
interface innovation galore it's
activating tell us about active ink and
how it changes our preconceptions about
inking thinking thinking the thing you
do a lot of these wonderful plays on
words it's just I love it as an English
major so yeah in fact you know we just
talked about data ink and data ink made
me realize how expressive the pen can be
and when I was thinking about this
project I was like I don't have to think
when I use the pen is just like you know
I'm just expressing myself and I don't
have to think about how I'm gonna do it
it's just so natural for me I just put
my band down and then that's the way it
goes and so how cool would it be if you
know I could use this for just
expressing my thinking all the time and
especially when I Joe is data or when I
work with documents and maps and
spreadsheets if I could just express
what I'm thinking or like
cross-referencing information from one
to the other with just my pen so that's
what active ink is and basically the
idea of active is you know when you have
everything imagine you have this big
canvas and you have all of your pieces
of information that matter and basically
we start drawing on top of it with your
pen you know to show connection between
them basically the system knows what
you've drawn on top to write they know
is the underlying content so it can sort
of transform the rest of the material
that you have on your screen and so
that's basically what we said the ink
become actives so you draw something
that's sort of your externalization of
your thinking right there it and then
the system sort of looks at what you've
circled there and then shows you
relevant information you know the way we
see the ink is sort of a deferred
command that you would do to the system
you didn't yet do the action but you
were gonna probably do this and so we
can actually just boom remove that
friction and that needs for you to go
and actually do that we could just do it
automatically so that's what actively is
about all right
so will you keep referring to this
system yes can you unpack that is that
the Internet is it data that I've
already collected where does all this
information come from that it knows ha
ha
well the system especially in my world
it's all about a web app ok so imagine
you go in a URL and then that's an
application there and we always sort of
assume that you have a bunch of document
leaving in the cloud right so we know
because you've logged in in some other
places like you know in your office 365
account we sort of know all of the
documents that you own or that you can
have access to and imagine you know it
would be like logging on one note and
just having some special capabilities
that we give to the digital ink okay
that lives in an app where we sort of
know your content and we can retrieve it
for you would it incorporate places that
I've looked on the web in terms of you
know searching for information and
things like that exactly and so that's
another component haha but yeah one
thing for example that we transfer from
pen and paper to active ink in the
digital world so you know how when you
you sort of read like documents you may
write a little Asterix
someplace right like on important
information or important paragraph and
then you put this Asterix and some other
places and so like as a reference or
bookmark so we sort of do this inactive
ink so when you browse the web you can
circle a part of a web page that you're
interested in and you could usually
refer it with the little symbol little
asterisks and so inactive ink then you
can just draw that same shape and like
search for similar ones and so it can
retrieve for you all of the little
shapes that were in other pages and then
just retrieve that part of the content
in the active in canvas so it's sort of
a way to gather information as well that
you've visited right even if you can't
remember that you visited it but you
might have made a mark on
and it comes back to you exactly date of
boomerangs every era has new media and
technologies and the requisite need for
literacy around them for better or worse
there's print media literacy digital
literacy computer literacy and now
you're suggesting that we need to add
data visualization literacy to the list
not only are you suggesting it but
you've actually created a platform for
it to be used in classrooms you call it
c'est la vie which is a lovely play on
words for the French c'est la vie that's
life that's data that's visualization
tell us about c'est la vie what is it
and why do we need it you know as I said
we're like sort of surrounded by data
and we're surrounded by visualization
everywhere including infographics but
you know there's not a place on social
media or on your newspaper there's not a
place that doesn't really have some
piece of visual information and yet
what's interesting you know since I have
those two kids I sort of know what you
learn in elementary school now this is
forgotten yeah right
but I find it interesting that you know
this part of the curriculum hasn't
really been updated there wasn't much to
start with like I don't really recall
having a you know classes on building
data but so this really just need that
that we need to sort of teach kids about
creating those visuals and decoding them
properly and if you look like we did
with a bunch of colleagues at Toronto
and Turkey actually we looked at a lot
of those K to 4 K to 12
material that teachers are using sort of
looking at the type of visualization
that they're encountering during the
school it's kind of scary like how sort
of a small amount there is it's mostly
you know bar chart and light charts not
even pie chart for you
from that we we sort of and then none of
them is digital either so there's a lot
of content that you can access on the
web like nowadays right and then you can
click on it and transform it so none of
that made its way into the curriculum as
far as we saw so we decided to build
that platform that sort of teaches kids
to represent data in different ways
through different visual mapping and
like some of the key idea we wanted to
conveys that data can be represented in
many different ways so the same data but
many different visuals and each of those
visual could convey very different
insights right about that data so I
wanted to try to convey this and then
also try to have some of the interaction
literacies so this sort of way you
interact with the visuals and you know
spread the conversation about just
thinking a little bit more critically
about visualization and one visual you
know does it accurately represent the
data or not and sort of spark a little
bit of thinking around this in the
classroom right I would imagine - going
back to the emotion thing you could
represent by a pie chart or ten
hamburgers and get a different emotional
response or you know visceral response
executive and then one of the core
findings that you know looking at all of
that material that happened in school is
that gradually over the years the
visuals go from very concrete you know
little Apple that you stack yeah to way
more abstract visual like a bar chart
okay but yet it was never made crisp to
the kids that those are the same data
different representation but of the same
data so we tried to convey this you know
how we go from a very concrete to very
abstract visual representation and then
try to convey you know what got lost in
translation right right the Apple is not
the Napo anymore but it's this red
square but yeah it represents the same
thing right and so we try to touch upon
some of those concept that you know the
visual can convey very interesting
semantics because if you have a picture
of an apple this very few data said that
could match that right exactly by the
red square anything yeah so there's a
lot of those concepts there so have you
just used this in research that you were
doing for a paper or is this in a
pipeline somewhere as well
Heights in a pipeline how much good
stuff that might be coming out yeah I'm
trying to build connection with the
hacking stem program that we have in
Microsoft and try to help them build
their data science and data literacy
curriculum and provide some component
that are visual interfaces for the kids
well we've reached once again the
infamous what could possibly go wrong
section of vodcast and on the heels of
that conversation about data
visualization literacy your research
revolves around making really powerful
tools that enable people to create
compelling and perhaps very persuasive
visual narratives so is there anything
about this that keeps you up at night
Natalie and if so what can we do about
it aside from saying I hope they use
their powers for good and not for evil
right well that's exactly the
inspiration behind the Salafis project
so with a bunch of colleagues we sat
down and we really reflected upon how
visualization is the superpower for
communication and as you mentioned it
could be very misleading you could like
you know use fake data but you could
also sort of tweak the visual to sort of
convey the opposite of what the data
tells you so we sort of sat down and
then reflected about what we can do what
can we do can we like and for some
design principle when you create the
visualization but I guess it's just
really hard because you could just make
up the data right and there's no way
really we can stop people from
collecting or crafting wrong datasets or
or visualizations thereof
so the only possibility that we saw and
then just you know please tell me if you
see others but the only possibility
sighs to educate people so that they
would know when they look at a
visualization to think of it critically
about it and to try to ponder you know
how is this collected you know is that
data missing is that representative data
set and also beyond that you know the
important question look at the visuals
and really try to change the way it's
represented in their mind like is that a
good mapping for it
yeah and so that's the motivation behind
going in schools and looking at
visualization literacy and trying to
help teach and you know help convey that
you have to think critically about those
pictures especially because those are
crafted by human beings they're not like
a photograph but those are truly
manipulated so many you know data is
curated visuals are chosen and selected
and so really try to educate people and
kids in particular to think more
critically about what information
they're consuming but you keep going
down the line and rightly so of
developing tools that will help people
communicate better and more powerfully
and you just have to hope with education
and being optimistic that you're not
gonna lose sleep over what people could
do wrong with it yes Natalie what's your
story this is the part of the podcast
where I like to ask where you came from
what got you interested in your career
particularly for you data visualization
research and how did you end up here at
Microsoft research all the way from
France so I guess I always wanted to be
an artist and when I told my mom I'm
gonna do a major in art she said that's
not gonna bring you know money on the
table and you can't live with this so
just do computer science instead and my
mom was a secretary and an accountant
and they just had to you know switch
everything to computers at the time so
she knew you know for her computer we're
going everywhere
that's gonna bring money on the table
right so she sort of decided for me
salmon by weights computer science and
then the funny story is once I was in
engineering school in France and I got
really bored by all these computer
science thing and I was still doing a
lot of arts and then I thought you know
what I'm big now I can choose for myself
so I'm gonna go have fun in Australia
cuz I wanted to visit and then I'm just
gonna give up all of this engineering
stuff and then she's gonna do my
painting career that I always wanted and
my idea of sort of not working and
having fun in Australia but yet sort of
finishing my degree was to end up in a
research lab so I picked this research
lab in Sydney and they were doing data
visualization but for me wasn't really
important I didn't even know what it was
and so when I got there I said you know
what I'll just show up and then I'll
just go to the beach because they don't
do anything in research right and then
when I started meeting these people and
they told me what they were doing I just
thought this is it I can do art with
data and computers and this is what I
want to do and so it's very interesting
because instead of just you know what I
envision which is you know go one hour
to the lab and then the rest on the
beach I sort of did the opposite in the
lab and then I did all of that research
and then when I came back to France in
the engineering school then I chose a
track where I could do my master's
degree at the same time and then a PhD
in that field right and the last year of
my PhD I did a joint project with
Microsoft Research and that's sort of
how I ended there the rest is a spa all
right this is my new favourite question
what's one interesting thing that people
might not know about you a trait a
characteristic a life event something
that may have influenced your career as
a researcher and even if it didn't tell
us something interesting about yourself
anyway you know I was really into
helping kids to think critically about
data and
I said I'll start with my daughter at
the time she was six and then we walked
down the park and then I said okay we're
gonna collect data about dogs and like
you know how big they are and their fur
and then you know after we've done that
for about an hour come back home and I'm
like I'm gonna create the next house
chart for you and we're gonna show you
you know how you transform that data
link to a chart which you know my
daughter is sort of nice but yet you
know it's doing all this in Excel and
she came in just like why don't you just
draw it and I had no good answer so I
thought maybe we should just do that
just throw it and that sort of way it
started me thinking about pen and touch
and you know the six-year-old chose the
best research first it's your mom
then it's your daughter yes well as we
close and I'm sad to close because I've
enjoyed this conversation very much you
get the last word what advice would you
give or thoughts would you share with
anyone in our audience who might be
interested in making beautiful data more
accessible so I guess what I've learned
is to rely a lot on my gut instincts and
listen to other people in my life you
know as you pointed out my mom and my
daughter but really when you have this
gut feeling that this is an interesting
direction even though it may look silly
right just comics really or draw
something really you know just follow up
that instinct and just try to develop
the idea and make it happen I guess
that's my piece of advice just try to
follow what you really think is a good
idea and then do it despite what
everyone else might say but because of
what everyone else is a natalie rish
it's been delightful thank you for
coming on the podcast today thank you so
much
to learn more about dr. Nathalie rish
and how researchers are helping us to
visualize world data visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides